Guten Morgen, Linus. Guten Morgen, Tim. Wissen wir eigentlich, was das Thema ist heute?
Werden wir sehen.
Tja, heute ist mal wieder alles anders, oder? Wie letztes Mal schon.
Wie immer. Aber trotzdem irgendwie. Das ist ja das Langweilige daran, dass es immer anders ist.
Ja, das stimmt.
Könnte man ja auch mal nicht anders sein.
Aber wir sind live. Wir sagen es gleich vorne weg, damit dir überhaupt keine Fragen erst aufkommen. Wir sind auch unter Beobachtung. Haben wir einen Stream? Es kann sein, dass das auch funktioniert dahinten. Das ans andere Ende des Internets zu blicken, ist ja immer recht schwer. Aber wir sind hier im Sendezentrum, live auf der Republika 13. Und wir haben auch ein Publikum. Hallo Publikum, hallo. Haben Sie verstanden mit dem Klatschen? Nicht nur das, wir haben auch einen Gast. Und zwar begrüßen wir Martin. Martin Delius. Guten Morgen.
Ja, guten Morgen. Um die Zeit.
Genau, vielleicht bist du ja das Thema.
Vielleicht bin ich das Thema. Das Thema?
Es dreht sich ja ohnehin eine Menge um dich. Vielleicht sollte man das auch noch mal kurz hier zur Eröffnung der Sendung betonen. Aber manche werden es schon wissen, du bist ja Teil der Fraktion der Piratenpartei in Berlin, im Abgeordnetenhaus, wie das so schön heißt, die sich ja bekanntermaßen aus 15 Leuten zusammensetzt. Davon bist du halt einer, aber außerdem hast du noch so das ein oder andere Amt an die Backe geklebt bekommen. Unter anderem die Leitung des Untersuchungsausschusses vom BER, das hat mir ja auch schon mal als Thema, als ihr eure Plattform da gestartet habt, da können wir eigentlich auch nochmal drüber sprechen. Und auch ansonsten hast du, glaube ich, keinen Mangel an Tätigkeit, oder?
Bin ja jetzt auch hier nicht wie so viele Kollegen, jetzt sind ja auch ein paar Abgeordnete aus NRW der Piraten auch hier, die warten hier Urlaub gemacht. Ich muss zwischendurch immer wieder ins Büro, ansonsten...
Weil die Urlaub machen.
Nicht weil die Urlaub machen, trotz dass die Urlaub machen, muss ich arbeiten. Ja, das ist eher so das Problem. Es gibt ja dann auch mal Sitzungen, wie das in der Politik so ist. Man muss dann sitzen und diskutieren und Beschlüsse fassen und sich entscheiden. Und so ein bisschen die Idee für den Podcast war ja auch mal zu gucken, was jetzt die Politik eigentlich machen soll mit dieser gegenwärtigen Situation in der Netzgemeinde.
Wir diskutieren die großen Lösungen.
Vielleicht auch nicht.
Oder auch nicht.
Die großen, den großen gordischen Knoten.
Steigen wir doch gleich mal ein. Womit wollen wir denn anfangen?
Also wir fangen glaube ich an, weil es die Hörerschaft so gewohnt ist, mit einer Kurzzusammenfassung der Themen dieser Woche, wobei ich aber schon direkt dazu sagen kann, dass ich ja hier, es ist ja gerade Republika und deshalb habe ich wenig mitbekommen und wenig lesen können, aber mir Mühe gegeben und die erste Meldung ist, dass es jetzt der Verbraucherzentrale Nordrhein-Westfalen, die Deutsche Telekom, wegen der Drossel, abgemahnt hat.
Der hier auch ein heißes Thema ist. Ich habe eine kleine Statistik gesehen, was die populärsten Twitter-User-Accounts sind, die in RP13-Tweets genannt werden und auf Platz 4 standen, drossel.com.
Ja, das ist der beliebte Satire-Account. Beim Start der Republika wurde von Markus auch schon das Statement gegen die Drossel-Pläne der Telekom laut in den dpa-Ticker geschrien.
Der ist bereit für dich aufzunehmen.
So wurde mir das gerichtet.
Das war wahrscheinlich der bestmögliche Slot, das gleich zu setzen, das Thema.
Ja und ich habe ja auch in meinem Vortrag heute ein Drossel-Konzept vorgestellt.
Ach wirklich?
Ja, die Troll-Drossel. Das ist aber ein ganz neutrales, nee, nee, das ist Troll-Wahrscheinlichkeit gleich Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du das Captcha nicht löst.
Thema erledigt.
Ich bin ja für Paid-Comments.
Paid-Comments?
Paid-Comments, großartiges Konzept. Macht das irgendjemand? Ich glaube, es war für irgendeine Onlinesparte ein größeren überregionalen Tageszeitung geplant. Sollte jetzt kommen. Paid-Comments.
Ja, toll, dann hast du da unten halt Werbung drunter, ne?
Die Nutzer kaufen sich dann so eine Flat und können sie 10 Kommentare am Tag hinterlassen? Das wäre doch mal was für unsere Blogs.
Das ist eine interessante Idee.
Auch ein Konzept. Ich weiß nicht, ob man so eine Community am Leben hält.
Ja, es könnte Schwierigkeiten geben. Aber wollen wir nicht einfach ein bisschen beim Thema bleiben? Also die Verbraucherschützer haben jetzt ihr Telekom abgemahnt und das auf Basis einer, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ist das eigentlich Gesetz oder ist das die Formulierung, dass die Nutzer das nicht erwarten dürfen? Wo steht denn das hier mit dieser Formulierung? Ich habe das woanders gelesen. Es gibt so in diesem ganzen Verbraucherschutzbestimmung so dieses, du darfst jetzt deine Verträge nicht einfach mal so ändern, wenn das sozusagen nicht zu erwarten war, das bezieht sich eher auf eine Vertragsänderung. Hier ist ja der Deal eigentlich der, dass die Telekom neue Verträge jetzt erstmal mit diesem neuen Regelwerk begleiten möchte, aber schon auch meinte, dass die anderen schon irgendwie alle nachziehen. Das hatte wahrscheinlich was mit der Umstellung auf IP zu tun und so weiter. Jetzt bin ich mir gerade nicht ganz so sicher, ob jetzt die Meldung, die du hier rausgekramt hast, sich auf dasselbe bezieht.
Also was die Verbraucherzentrale selber so verlautbaren lässt, bezieht sich dann auf die starke Drosselung. Also es ist ja hauptsächlich sagen, die Drosselung ist zu stark und auch darauf rumreiten, dass es eben 99,2 Prozent langsamer wird und die diskriminierungsfreien Zugang einschränkt. Das Interessante bei dieser Abmahnung ist eigentlich nur, dass sie sagen, bis zum 16. Mai, also in einer Woche, Donnerstag in einer Woche, soll die Telekom eine Unterlassungserklärung unterzeichnen.
Das sind sie geliefert.
Sonst müssen sie zahlen. Sonst müssen Gerichte entscheiden, ob die Drossel-Klausel zulässig ist oder nicht. Ich halte die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Telekom jetzt diese Unterlassungserklärung abgibt, für sehr gering. Das heißt, die mit anderen Worten, die Verbraucherzentrale in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat ihre Bereitschaft, ihre Bereitschaft Ausdruck verliehen, dagegen auch zu klagen. Aber Verbraucherzentralen arbeiten dann über Argumente des Verbraucherschutzes. Das heißt, da wird es wahrscheinlich genau darum gehen, dass die Drosselung dann zu stark ist und nicht zu mutbar.
Das Argument ist ja eigentlich, das Internet ist dann funktional kaputt. Also das, was die Verbraucherzentrale sagt, ist, du erfüllst deine vertraglichen Zusicherungen nicht mehr. Telekom, wenn du das drosselst, dann erfüllst du deinen Teil des Vertrags nicht mehr.
Also wenn das natürlich explizit im Vertrag drinsteht, dass das so ist.
Ja, aber das ist halt wahrscheinlich das, was dann das Gericht entscheiden muss. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass die Telekom jetzt die Gerichtskosten oder das Urteil scheuen muss.
Also stimmt, das Gericht müsste dann, also das einzige Urteil, was da zur Debatte steht, ist dann über die Höhe der Drosselung.
Ja, das ist ja...
Dann könnte es sein, dass das Gericht sagt, ja, ein Gutachten sagt uns, das ist wenig und deshalb sollte die Drosselung nicht ganz so stark sein?
Na, wahrscheinlich ist es so eine Verhältnismäßigkeitsentscheidung. Also das Gericht muss dann halt entscheiden, ob das Ziel, jemandem Internet zu bieten, noch erfüllt ist, wenn man mit 384 Kilobits pro Sekunde durch die Gegend juckelt.
Ja, also man merkt auch schon wirklich die Hilflosigkeit auf allen Seiten. Also es herrscht eine Argumentationsschwäche wirklich überall, weil die eigentliche Frage, die ja hier im Raum steht, ist überhaupt so eine Drosselung an sich in einem Festnetz stadthaft oder nicht. Weil die Telekom ja letzten Endes eigentlich, wenn man ihren eigenen Aussagen folgt, gibt es ja gar kein Problem, weil sie sagen, der Durchschnitt liegt bei 15 bis 20 Gigabyte im Monat. Wenn das der Durchschnitt ist, dann können ja die paar, die jetzt mehr verbrauchen, das Gesamtsystem nicht nennenswert ins Wanken bringen. Und Insider haben ja auch ausführlich schon dokumentiert, dass es einfach kein Kapazitätsproblem im Backend gibt, sondern das eigentliche Problem sind eigentlich immer noch die Anschlussbitraten auf der letzten Meile und die werden dann halt einfach erzielt oder nicht. Beziehungsweise man kauft ja das teurere Produkt überhaupt bei der Telekom, weil es dann schneller ist, weil man dann natürlich damit auch mehr Daten übertragen kann.
Und man bezahlt Anschlussgebühren. Das Argument von Clemens kam jetzt glaube ich in irgendeinem Podcast. Die Anschlussgebühren sind ja eigentlich genau das, was sicherstellen soll, dass die technischen Voraussetzungen da sind, dass man die schnelleren Bits bekommt und auch das größere Volumen.
Genau, und man zahlt überhaupt auch regelmäßig irgendwie Gebühren und diese Gebühren sollten eben dafür ausreichen, dass diese Dienstleistungen dann eben, nämlich der schnelle Anschluss, auch gewährleistet werden kann. Der Treffig selber quält sie halt kaum. Also das können sie zumindest nicht belegen und nachweisen und eigentlich auch ihrer eigenen Aussage her scheint in dieser ganzen Debatte noch keiner auf die Idee gekommen zu sein, diese Spur einzunehmen, weil sie halt gleich daherkommen mit dem Argument, naja, wieso beim Mobilfunk ist das halt auch so, nur dass halt natürlich ein Mobilfunkkabel nicht dieselben Eigenschaften aufweist, wie ein in die Erde gelegtes Kupferkabel.
Und auch beim Mobilfunk müsste das nicht so sein, bin ich der Meinung. Die technische Realität ist mir da jetzt nicht ganz geläufig, aber ich glaube auch nicht dran, dass wir bis zum Sankt-Nimmerleins-Tag Volumenbegrenzung beim Mobilfunk brauchen.
Ja gut, aber du hast ja auf jeden Fall ein Shared Medium. Das hast du halt beim Festnetzanschluss nicht, sondern da hast du ja deine eigene Leitung bis an die Stelle, wo es eben keinerlei Verknappung mehr geben sollte. Beim Mobilfunk benutzt du zwangsläufig dasselbe Kabel. Man könnte eher von einem Kabelprovider sowas erwarten.
Also du kriegst nicht unbegrenzt Daten in den Frequenzen unter?
Ja, das liegt aber an den Frequenzen. Das liegt aber daran, dass wir nicht...
Ja, das soll sich mit LTE jetzt ändern. Jetzt wird LTE auf viel mehr Frequenzen gemacht. Man bemüht sich da um Effizienz. Aber letztendlich kann man da argumentieren, dass es da irgendwo eine Grenze zu erreichen gibt.
Es gibt eine Bandbreite Grenze. Genau.
Und bei Krabeln könntest du ja immer noch mal eins daneben legen.
Ja, man kann, glaube ich, einfach festhalten, es gibt einfach zu wenig Wettbewerb in diesem Bereich. Und die Telekom kann da halt einfach machen, was sie will. Und sie will halt jetzt eigentlich mehr einnehmen, so indem sie noch eine zweite Premium-Klasse Internet schafft. Nur, dass sie einem auch nicht genau sagt, was jetzt eigentlich das Angebot ist. Also, was bezahle ich dann irgendwie wieder? Wird das Bit dann wieder vergoldet? Ja, das goldene Bit?
Naja, am Ende, ich glaube, das wurde ja auch schon mehrfach gesagt, am Ende soll es halt darum gehen, dass es Managed Services gibt. Also Spotify ist ja, glaube ich, gibt es da schon das Angebot? Oder war das nur eine Ankündigung?
Gibt es bisher nur im Mobilfunk, aber sie haben angekündigt, dass sie sich derartige Zusammenarbeit natürlich auch sehr gut vorstellen können.
Das haben wir alles letzte Woche schon. Deswegen bin ich ja eigentlich auch hier, oder deswegen bin ich nicht auf die Idee dieser Sondersendung gekommen. Wir sind ja auf dieser Internetkonferenz. Und da soll es ja im Prinzip auch darum gehen, so ein bisschen die, also verstehe ich das, die Zukunft zu beschreiben. Jetzt merke ich, da hast du schon gesagt, drossel.com ist in aller Munde, ist ja auf vielen Sessions und Workshops und alle fragen sich jetzt, was machen wir jetzt damit? Und es herrscht eine große Ratlosigkeit. Der Internetnutzer und Microblogger Ed Tante hat es sehr schön aufgeschrieben. Die fehlschlaginduzierte Depression der Netzszene schlägt sich auf diese Veranstaltung nieder. Das Gefühl habe ich auch. Jetzt sitze ich hier als Pirat. Ich denke, die Piraten können das auch nachvollziehen. So eine Art Depression, die durchaus auch fehlschlaginduziert ist. Ich glaube aber auch, dass das für den Rest von uns durchaus gilt, weil ich merke nicht, dass sich hier so ein Bild entfaltet, nachdem ich entscheiden kann, wie geht es denn jetzt weiter? Haken wir jetzt bis zur nächsten Republik auf der Telekom rum? Oder, das sind ja noch ein paar andere Links hier drinnen, machen Verfassungsbeschwerden gegen die Bestandsdatenauskunft, kämpfen gegen Zista, die Akternachfolger oder haben wir den Mut und den Drive, was eigenes zu machen, eine eigene Agenda zu setzen? Weil die sehe ich nämlich nicht. Was sowohl die Piratenpartei macht, als auch die Netzgemeinde an sich, ist halt den aktuellen Entwicklungen hinterher zu laufen und zu sagen, nee, das will ich nicht. Ich will keine Vorratssteinsspeicherung, ich will keinen LSR, ich will keine Telekom-Drossel. Aber was wollen wir denn dann? Und wie finden wir raus, was wir wollen? Das ist eigentlich das, weswegen ich auf so eine Konferenz hier gehe. Das würde ich gern wissen. Das möchte ich auf Panels diskutiert sehen, das möchte ich in Vorträgen sehen und das fehlt mir.
Also zumindest für Drossel, glaube ich, ist relativ klar. Also ich persönlich räume jetzt dieser Beschwerde von der Verbraucherzentrale nicht besonders große Chancen ein, weil es halt irgendwie so Verbraucherschutz ist. Verbraucherschutz ist Killifit. Du brauchst Grundrechte, du brauchst irgendwie ein klares Gesetz, was dir Dinge verbietet und das muss nicht ein Verbraucherschutzgesetz sein, sondern es muss einfach irgendwie so ein ernstenehmes Gesetz sein, was den Leuten auch entsprechend angesiedelt ist. Und da ist natürlich schon klar und wird ja seit Jahren, also fordern wir TM, seit Jahren, dass die Netzneutralität, die musst du halt gesetzlich festlegen. Ich habe da gestern mit Max, der ja auch gerade hier noch sitzt, mich darüber unterhalten. Es gibt einfach nichts, was die Telekom daran hindert, so ein Tarifmodell zu machen. Das können die einfach so machen. Und maximal kann die, so würde ich jetzt mit meiner Leiheneinschätzung sagen, maximal kriegt die Verbraucherzentrale da irgendwie durch, dass das auf ein zumutbares Niveau von 650 Kilobit gedrosselt wird oder was auch immer der Richter sich dann da ausdenkt.
Aber das ist ja nicht das, was wir wollen.
Genau, das ist nicht das, was wir wollen.
Genau, wir wollen Gras. Und wie kriegen wir jetzt Philipp Rößler dazu, dass er mehr tut, als einen Brief zu schreiben? Wir haben in Piratenfraktionen gestern einen wunderbaren Antrag beschlossen für eine Bundesratsinitiative. Mehr können wir ja nicht machen, wenn es um Bundesthemen geht, in der wir schön aufgeschlüsselt haben, was wir wollen, dass Netzneutralität ist und dass es durchgesetzt wird. So, toller Antrag. Kann ich verlinken, könnt ihr euch durchlesen. Ist vielleicht noch nicht vollständig, kann man irgendwie über noch mehr diskutieren. Aber wir wissen alle, dass es das am Ende auch nicht bringen wird, weil weder die Bundesregierung auf Bundesratsvotum noch die Berliner Große Koalition jetzt beschließen wird, die Netzneutralität einzuführen. Also wie kriegen wir, und das ist ja auch das, was Sascha am Montag gesagt hat, wie kriegen wir Philipp Rößler und Angela Merkel überzeugt? Wie kriegen wir, was weiß ich, Per Steinbrück dazu, dass er Netzneutralität will?
Nicht wählen könnte er da zum Beispiel schon mal helfen. Ansonsten frage ich mich eigentlich, wie sehr sich Deutschland eigentlich von dieser Idee, dass dieser Wohlstand dieses Landes auf seiner guten Infrastruktur basiert, entfernt hat. Das ist mir wirklich ein Rätsel. Weil da geht es doch wirklich massiv zurück und die Erkenntnis, dass uns das gute Telefonnetz eben lange Zeit auch wirklich einen erheblichen Vorsprung geboten hat, scheint sich irgendwie nicht rumgesprochen zu haben. Das ist in gewisser Hinsicht völlig absurd. Und ganz klar, man muss da glaube ich auch einfach ganz krasse Forderungen auf den Tisch legen und sagen, irgendwie 10 Megabit Synchron für Oma Dutschke irgendwie auf dem Dorf.
Ich bin ja bei 1 Gigabit, aber ich würde halt oben anfangen.
Ja, Gegenaufpreis, ich würde sagen für 5 Euro mehr.
Wir können uns das alles vorstellen und ich glaube, das findet auch eine Mehrheit. Egal, weil du sagst, Linus, dass wir wollen das ja schon lange. Die Frage ist halt, wer ist wir? Jetzt merke ich halt immer wieder, wenn ich so mit Leuten rede, auch gerade auf der Republika hier, das gibt schon eine große und auch sicherlich gerechtfertigte Enttäuschung, was die Piraten angeht, aber auch sicherlich was irgendwie andere. Ich meine, wenn es Sozialpolitik angeht, ist hier Enttäuschung bei der SPD. Es gibt dann immer wieder diese Erwartungshaltung an einzelne Parteien, irgendwas zu tun und das durchzubekommen, wenn es dann aber nicht passiert, weil zum Beispiel in Berlin 135.000 Leute, die Piraten nicht gewählt haben, wegen Netzpolitik, wegen anderen Dingen, wegen irgendwie Protestpotenzial und Transparenz und Demokratie und all diesen schönen Teilen. Kiffen, genau, frei kiffen. Religion ist doof, war auch ein Grund. Überhaupt alles doof. Und dann passiert das nicht und dann ist tatsächlich, dann ist auch der Drive raus. Ich merke das hier gerade. Es ist jetzt so, wir unterhalten uns hier gerade, was schön wäre, so 10 Megabit, einen Gigabit, ja, wie?
Piraten schon seit zwei Jahren im Amt und mein Netz ist immer noch langsam.
Genau, so 3,50 Euro, nie wieder Piraten. Also, wie kommen wir da jetzt wieder raus? Sitzen wir bei der Republikar 14 immer noch da und meckern darüber, dass die EU-Datenschutz-Verordnung scheiße ist? Wenn sie dann bis dahin durch ist und so scheiße ist, wie sich das jetzt abzeichnet?
Oder kommt so eine gute Idee? Man stimmt ja völlig zu. Man muss halt jetzt Visionen definieren. Es ist halt einfach ganz klar. Wobei im Wesentlichen ist es irgendwie auch klar, oder? Man gibt es da noch irgendwelche Zweifel.
Was die Vision ist? Ja. Ich habe viele Visionen.
Es muss halt einfach ein, wie nennt man solche Projekte immer, was war das letzte so, Aufbau Ost irgendwie? Aufbau, keine Ahnung, ob Aufbau jetzt das richtige Wort ist. Man muss halt einfach massiv, quasi so eine Art Mondlandung im Bezug auf Internetausbau. So wie die USA sich irgendwie in die Bresche geworfen haben, um diese fucking Rakete auf den Mond zu kriegen, so müssen wir halt irgendwie die Glasfaser oben auf den Berg kriegen. Mit allen nur irgendwie erdenklichen Anstrengungen. Da setzt man sich irgendwie ein schönes Ziel, was weiß ich, nicht gerade übermorgen, aber halt so in ein paar Jahren haben wir das irgendwie erreicht. Und wer dann irgendwie immer noch keine Glasfaser zu Hause hat, die auch funktioniert und wo irgendwie schnell die 10 Megabit rauskommen, der darf dann halt vom Menschen im Gerichtshof so was wie der Menschenrechtsverbrecher klagen.
Nach der Agenda 2010 der Uplink 2020?
Uplink 2020 ist ein schöner Name.
Als Initiative der Bundesregierung der scheidenden und wiederkehrenden Bundesregierung, dass sie sagt, jetzt machen wir noch den Uplink 2020 in Traub natürlich.
Okay, wir denken uns da noch an Ketchy.
Vielleicht müssen wir doch die aktuelle politische Situation in Betracht ziehen.
Ja, nicht nur vielleicht, sondern unbedingt. Ich kann dem Uplink 2020 auch viel abgewinnen. Ich werde ja nur öfter mal auf der Straße von irgendwelchen Berlinern angesprochen. Ey, du bist doch der Pirat. Ja, eben nicht mein WLAN geht nicht, sondern warum sind die Mieten so hoch? Warum ist das Klo in der Schule meiner Tochter scheiße? Warum tropft es von der Decke der Turnhalle? Warum habe ich so viele Schlaglöcher in der Straße? Darüber werde ich vielleicht angesprochen. Ich werde nicht auf Internet angesprochen. Ich werde nicht auf Telekom angesprochen.
Du bist aber auch politisch im Bereich angesiedelt, wo man dir jetzt nur wenige Chancen einräumt.
Aber auch bei Mieten und bei Straßenbau räumt man mir keine Chancen ein.
Dafür mache ich dich jeden Morgen verantwortlich, wenn ich mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit fahre.
Bei mir ist das nämlich egal, ich fahre nämlich Taxi.
Weil ihr die Dienstfahrräder nicht bekommen habt.
Das ist halt der Punkt, das ist das, was die Leute breit interessiert. 10 Megabit Up und Down in einer vernünftigen Flatrate ohne Drossel mit einem Breitbandausbau, was sie ablenkt, 2020, das interessiert halt irgendwie 3%. Und nicht diejenigen, die mich auf der Straße ansprechen und nicht die Mehrheit.
Hier natürlich die Mehrheit. Ja, aber scheiß drauf, das war in den 60er Jahren, weil bestimmt der Telefonanschluss für alle auch nicht unbedingt jetzt das Thema.
Ja, nur wie ist es dazu gekommen, dass es das Thema wurde und wie ist es dazu gekommen, dass sich im Parlament die Mehrheiten gefunden haben, das Geld locker zu machen, das auszubauen? Und wie schaffen wir das, dass es wieder passiert? Das ist das, was ich sage. Das ist die Frage. Und die Frage, sorry, da bin ich jetzt Mitglied der Partei, die stelle ich an die Aktivisten. Wie kriegen wir das hin? Klar kann ich Gesetzesentwürfe der DigiGest ins Parlament einbringen. Nur wie überzeugt die SPD, die von sich behauptet, wir sind auch nicht wegen Bildungspolitik gewählt worden, deswegen kümmern wir uns nicht drumrum, wie überzeugt die, dass das ein Thema ist, wo sie Geld locker machen soll? Indem Oma Lisien sagt, ich will Internet.
Also Oma Lisien ist schuld?
Oma Lisien ist nicht schuld, Oma Lisien weiß nicht, dass sie Internet möchte. Oder Oma Lisien muss erst erklärt werden, dass Internet toll ist, vielleicht für Enkelkinder.
Jetzt müssen wir wieder was einfallen lassen, womit ich Oma Lisien überzeugen kann.
Genau, das ist der Punkt. Oma Lisien zu überzeugen.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an diese... Du sagst quasi, du machst jetzt die Landbevölkerung oder das hohe Durchschnittsalter der Gesellschaft verantwortlich?
Nee, verantwortlich mache ich die Politik, die sich nicht darum gekümmert hat, einen Infrastrukturausbau zu machen. Aber ich kann auch genauso gut verstehen, dass sie sich nicht darum gekümmert hat, weil sie sich stattdessen um Arbeitsplätze kümmern wollte oder zumindest so getan hat, als ob sie sich darum kümmert. Oder was weiß ich, um die Sozialsysteme, eben nicht um Internetinfrastruktur.
Ja, das verstehe ich. Infrastruktur ist eine Sache, das ist schlimm und tragisch, aber da sind natürlich die Provider, wir haben das ja auch ausführlich schon mal besprochen, in ökonomischen Gegebenheiten ausgesetzt, dass es natürlich für sie einfach sehr, sehr viel interessanter ist, das Netz in Berlin auszubauen als irgendwie der letzten Rentnerin irgendwo auf dem Berg ein DSL dahin zu legen, was sie im Zweifelsfall gar nicht nutzt. Das sehe ich als ein Problem an, aber wie mit unserem Netz als solches dann auch noch mal umgegangen wird, das sehe ich dann noch mal als ein anderes Problem an, also siehe Bestandsdatenauskunft, das nächste Thema, was habe ich noch so auf der Liste?
Ja, wollen wir mal zum nächsten Thema übergehen, weil die Diskussion dreht sich im Kreis.
Das ist genau mein Problem. Dreht sich nämlich immer im Kreis.
Jetzt gerade zumindest.
Also, die Bestandsdatenauskunft wurde sehr problemlos vom Bundesrat abgesegnet. Ich glaube, das hatten wir auch schon berichtet, ich bin mir gar nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, aber es gibt jetzt immerhin auch von einem Piraten, also der gute Mann ist auch Pirat, eine Verfassungsbeschwerde dagegen. Und zwar wurden die angestrengt von dem Patrick Breyer, der ist im Kieler Landtag und auch seit Jahren bekannt im AK Vorrat. Und Katharina Nocun, wie spricht man das aus?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Keine Ahnung, die haben eine eigene Website dafür gebastelt und sagen, wir strengen jetzt wirklich die Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen dieses Gesetz an. Sie wurden beraten von Meinhard Starostik.
Den kennen wir auch schon.
Der ist auch bekannt.
Mit dem habt ihr eine besondere Vergangenheit, richtig?
Mit dem haben wir glaube ich alle eine besondere Vergangenheit, die wir hier sitzen. Wie heißt es die Massenklage gegen?
Vorratsdatenspeichung.
Genau. Und dank der Piraten in Berlin ist er jetzt auch Landesverfassungsrichter in Berlin. Das ist eigentlich ein Ehrenamt, das muss man dazu sagen. Dafür kriegt man keine Kohle. Aber er darf da auf jeden Fall über die Landesverfassung wachen. Und der hat die beraten. Ich finde es gut, dass sie das gemacht haben. Es ist aber auch wieder das Problem. Das kommt jetzt von Piraten. Die Frage ist, kommen wir dann wieder in diesen üblichen Streit? Wer hat es erfunden? Wer macht jetzt mit, wenn das von Piraten kommt, macht dann die Digiges mit? Wenn das von Piraten kommt, bewegt sich dann das Chaos? Ich hoffe, dass das nicht passiert, aber die Gefahr besteht natürlich. Weil das kennen wir ja aus der Vergangenheit. Ob das jetzt ein YouTube-Video ist, das falsch lizenziert wurde, oder was war das letzte, die Urheberrechtspetition? War das eine Urheberrechtspetition, die von dem Bruno Gerd Kramm gestartet wurde, die halt auch nicht erfolgreich war? Leistungsschutzrecht. Genau, und da war es ja das Gleiche. Das ist immer das Anstrengende, das sind gute Sachen. Aber wenn man das jetzt aus einer Partei heraus startet, dann hat man halt das Risiko, dass man auch polarisiert und am Ende keine Mehrheiten gewinnt.
Ja, also, sich innerhalb der Netzbewegungen gegenseitig irgendwie abgrenzen zu wollen, halte ich für die bescheuertste Idee. Deswegen trete ich ja auch immer, zumindest mit wechselnden Gruppierungen. Persönlich auf und denke, das sollten eigentlich alle tun. Das ist ein bisschen blöd. Das ergibt sich ja daraus, dass dieser Aktivismus leider auch irgendwoher finanziert werden muss. Wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, Markus Becke, andere Meister haben ja in dieser Netzpolitik-Org-Aufstellung mal gesagt, was sie für dieses Medium verdienen, was ja sehr wenig ist. Das heißt, die wollen ja gar nicht viel Geld. Wenn man aber sagt, man möchte jetzt eine Vollzeitangestellte oder mehrere Vollzeitangestellte haben, die sich um solche Dinge kümmern als Aktivisten, dann musst du auch für deren Auskommen sorgen. Weil sonst stellst du einfach nicht sicher, dass die dann, wenn die Scheiße in den Ventilator fliegt, auch da sind, um sich darum zu kümmern oder bzw. dann schon was vorbereitet haben. D.h. du brauchst irgendwie professionelle Aktivisten. Und die wiederum musst du ja irgendwie mit Geld finanzieren. Es gibt aber aus mir unklaren Gründen relativ wenig Geld für diesen Aktivismus. Also die Spenden halten sich da in Grenzen. Das geht in so Wellen. Markus hatte das in unserem Vortrag auf dem 29C3 mal dargestellt, dass du mit bestimmten kleinen Aufregern plötzlich eine riesen Menge Kohle anfahren kannst und dann aber für die notwendige Basisarbeit kaum Geld bekommst. Deswegen werden die sich immer gegen diese zweckgebundenen Spenden, die wollen sie immer nicht haben. Und jetzt hast du mehrere solche Gruppierungen. Und das heißt, um die Mittel, das kleine bisschen Geld, was so eine Aufregung bringt, da konkurrieren die auch tatsächlich. Und dann neidet dann, was weiß ich, der NGO A, der NGO B, die Spenden zur Website. Und da wird dann, was weiß ich, sich dann darüber eschöpft, dass das alles wenig Arbeit war, was die gemacht haben, oder es hätte zu nichts geführt. Und natürlich ist das auch, es ist auch tatsächlich, diese Zwänge sind halt da. Und die müssen halt erstmal weg.
Im Übrigen deswegen finanzieren wir in Deutschland Parteien, weil wir diese Zwänge in der politischen Willensbildung nicht haben wollen, wie es z.B. in Amerika der Fall ist.
Warum hat die Piratenpartei eigentlich keine Stiftung?
Weil wir das Geld nicht haben. Du kannst einen Verein gründen, darüber gibt es mehrere Modelle. Es gibt den Teil, der will es eher klassisch machen, und es gibt den Teil, der sagt, wir wollen es mit Feedback machen, und jeder soll eintreten können, und dann wird entschieden, welches Geld man ausgibt. Aber man hat im Prinzip erst dann eine Stiftung oder überhaupt die Möglichkeit, wirklich was zu reißen, wenn man das Geld vom Bundestag überwiesen kriegt. Und das passiert erst dann, wenn man im Bundestag ist.
Erst im Bundestag?
Ja, die Landesparlamente haben keine Stiftungsmittel. Und das Geld kommt halt von der Bundestagsverwaltung, also Lammert überweist das, genauso wie die Parteienfinanzierung. Das soll ja auch getrennt sein, legislative, exekutive, nicht die Bundesregierung entscheidet das, sondern der Bundestagspräsident, der prüft dann auch die Rechnung. Und daher kommt das Geld für solche Stiftungen.
Also die Stiftungen wie Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung, Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung, Rosa Luxemburg, Konrad Adenauer. Und haben die FDP, wie heißt deren Stiftung?
Gute Frage. Naumann. Friedrich-Naumann-Stiftung. Genau, daher soll ja das Geld kommen, stark institutionalisiert für politische Willensbildung, Campaigning, Aktivismus. Das haben wir halt nicht im Bereich Netzaktivismus. Ich meine, klar, die Berl-Stiftung finanziert auch coole Panels und coole Veranstaltungen in dem Bereich. Sogar die Friedrich-Naumann-Stiftung macht was in Sachen Bürgerrechten und auch die Konrad Adenauer-Stiftung. Aber jetzt wirklich konzentriert eben auf diesen Bereich, wie mache ich Campaigning, wo kriege ich irgendwie die Stellen her, die dann die Gesetzesinitiativen schreiben oder Stellungnahmen zu irgendwelchen Aufregern. Das gibt es nicht. Wo jetzt dann auch so die Piratenparteien helfen kann, also für unsere Fraktion kann ich das sagen, wir können halt recherchieren. Wir haben halt Personalmittel, wir können halt Know-how tatsächlich mit einbringen in den Diskurs, muss nur angefragt werden. Also der André Meister, genau, der rennt halt auch rum wegen der Funkzellenabfrage und schreibt kleine Anfragen. Die schreibt er, die lässt er möglicherweise dann von Fraktion und Fraktionsmitarbeiter nochmal prüfen, die werden dann weitergeleitet. So kriegt man Informationen, so kriegt man auch irgendwie die Zahlen, die man braucht, um Companion zu machen, so 135.000 Abfragen in Berlin allein im letzten Jahr, solche Dinge. Da können wir direkt helfen. Und auch vielleicht diese Neiddebatte, ich finde es schade, dass es nur eine Neiddebatte ist. Wenn es eine inhaltliche Debatte wäre, wäre ich damit viel glücklicher, aber das geht ja auch nicht nur ums Geld. Es geht ja auch darum, wer zuerst da war.
Das finden wir dann zu erbärmlich. Ich glaube nicht unbedingt, dass es eine Neiddebatte ist, sondern das sind einfach wirklich ökonomische Zwänge, denen die NGO dann unterworfen ist. Und hier kann nichts besseres passieren, als irgendwie ein städtes Einkommen zu haben, mit dem du einfach sagen kannst, damit stelle ich jetzt jemand ein. Deswegen bemüht sich ja die digitale Gesellschaft darum, Spendenmitglieder zu bekommen. Ich glaube, da verrate ich nicht zu viel, dass die digitale Gesellschaft die ganze Zeit dabei ist, sich auf irgendwelche Töpfe von irgendwelchen Stiftungen zu bewerben, um irgendwie mal eine Planungssicherheit zu bekommen. Und das ist etwas, was mich dann persönlich sehr daran ankotzt, ist, dass sie dann auf einmal, das ist so umschlicht, dass sie so viel damit beschäftigt, sich selber überhaupt erstmal zu finanzieren, dass da wiederum riesiger Overhead entsteht, wo dann nichts passiert. Und dann sitzen sie auf einmal da und verbringen die Hälfte ihrer Zeit damit, sich selbst am Leben zu erhalten und nicht zu wirken.
Deswegen sag ich ja, um dann auch nochmal zu dem Punkt zurückzukommen, dieser Verfassungsbeschwerde, wie kann man das Problem jetzt irgendwie abmeldern? Es ist ja nicht so, dass es in dieser ganzen Aktivisten-Szene bei Institutionen nicht auch Geld gäbe. Also ich weiß, dass die digitale Courage jetzt nicht gerade am Hungertuch nagt. Die haben Geld, die können Dinge finanzieren, die können auch große Demos mitfinanzieren und solche Sachen. Wieso kriegt man es dann nicht hin, eine Arbeitsteilung zu machen? Die DigiGes kümmert sich ums Politische, der CCC kümmert sich ums Technische, die Digital-Courage macht den Aktivismus und malt die Transparente. Und wegen mir, Piratenpartei, Grüne, Linke, SPD, FDP, wen auch immer man kriegt, macht er kleine Anfragen, holt die Daten aus den Parlamenten raus, die man sonst nicht kriegt. Das wäre doch eine sinnvolle Herangehensweise. Das passiert aber nicht. Wenn jetzt hier diese sinnvolle Initiative, die Verfassungsbeschwerde von Piraten gestartet wird, erwarte ich, kann ich die Uhr nachstellen. Der Erste kommt und sagt, das ist von Piraten, da mache ich nicht mit.
Das würde mich jetzt in dem Fall auch wundern.
Ich hoffe, dass ich falsch liege. Ich habe das Argument so oft gehört, man traut sich ja auf Demos, gar nicht mit Piratenshirt aufzutauchen. Weil du willst es ja nur für Parteiverbung nutzen. Ja, verdammt, ich bin Mitglied einer Partei. Ich hoffe, dass es uns allen was bringt, dass ich Mitglied einer Partei bin, sonst würde ich das nicht machen. Aber dann kacke ich mich doch dafür nicht an. Ich kacke dich doch auch nicht dafür an, dass du Mitglied einer DigiGas bist. Auch die DigiGas hat ja das gleiche Problem. Da gab es ja die Diskussion darum, wie grün ist die DigiGas. Völlig blödsinnige Diskussion. Das braucht man nicht, aber das sind Debatten, die man nicht braucht, die uns bremsen, die ganze Zeit, immer wieder, wo eine Arbeitsteilung tatsächlich weiterhelfen könnte. Wo man einen Schwung haben entwickeln kann, dadurch, dass man eben da, wo man kompetent ist oder möglicherweise Ressourcen hat, die andere nicht haben, die man zur Verfügung stellt, insoweit das im gesetzlichen Rahmen möglich ist, gerade bei Fraktionen, das ist ja manchmal nicht so einfach, echt was reißen könnte. Da fehlt mir, also ich kann jetzt auch sagen, du kannst jetzt meckern, und eigentlich hab ich auch nichts dafür getan, dass das besser wird. Die Frage ist, auf welcher Plattform kann man das besser machen? Weil wir jetzt auch beide Republikar sind, ich sag's noch mal, ich verstehe eigentlich, so eine Republikar genau als so eine Plattform, sowas zu diskutieren. Wenn ich gestern bei dem wunderbaren Re-Campaign-Workshop war, von Milena, die saßen hier gerade, wir müssen reden bei der letzten Sendung, drosselkommend das Thema, da haben wir auch diskutiert. Da war ich da, irgendwie Politik, auch ein Mitarbeiter der Piratenfraktion aus NRW, hat sich da auch daran beteiligt, sagt hier, wir sind in Bonn bei der Hauptversammlung und machen da Demonstrationen. Dann waren eben auch andere dabei, change.org, digitale Gesellschaft war, glaube ich, auch irgendwie vertreten. Das ist dann mal der Ansatz einer solchen Plattform, wo man sich austauschen kann, wer macht jetzt was? Aber dazu kommt es nicht, weil zeitliche Gründe, weil die Veranstaltung nicht darauf ausgerichtet ist. Und sowas fehlt einfach. Und ohne so eine Plattform, und ich bringe das, gehe nochmal an das Thema zurück, weil es dann einen schönen Vergleich gibt, was die Infrastruktur angeht. In Berlin gehen die Menschen auf die Straße und sammeln Unterschriften für ein Stadtwerk, für Energieversorgung, für Wasserversorgung und so weiter und so fort, weil sie gesehen haben, Privatisierung ist doof. Wollen wir nicht mehr, wir wollen das in staatlicher Hand haben, wir wollen den Infrastrukturausbau finanzieren. Wie kommen wir dazu, dass die Leute, und damit meine ich nicht die drei Hanseln, die hier sind, sondern die Menschen, die mich auf der Straße ansprechen, für den Internet- Infrastrukturausbau Volksinitiativen, Staaten und Unterschriften sammeln? Das ist der Punkt. Wir kommen im Moment nicht dahin, das muss man attestieren.
Und am wenigsten, indem wir Grabenkämpfe führen.
Genau.
Du sprichst mir aus der Seele.
Was hat die Bundesregierung für uns jemals getan? Wollen wir mal so thematisch ein bisschen voranschreiten?
Tim ist langweilig.
Nö, lass nicht, aber ich finde, den Punkt haben wir jetzt auch ausführlich zusammengerührt. Da kommt jetzt nicht mehr viel. Linus, womit machen wir weiter?
Ich denke, um noch so ein bisschen, wir haben ja glaube ich ausreichend besprochen, wie scheiße es ist. Und um einfach nur zu sagen, dass es auch bei den anderen scheiße ist, in den USA soll jetzt wieder diskutiert werden, dass man dem FBI den Zugriff auf Chats ermöglicht. Und zwar haben sie ein bisschen Probleme mit diesen Online-Plattformen, die jetzt nicht irgendwie Standards nutzen. Und da kommen sie mit ihren Abhörmethoden irgendwie nicht dran. Seitdem die jetzt alle, um Aktivisten in fernen Ländern zu schützen, SSL-Verschlüsseln nutzen, diese auch in den USA nutzen, sagt das FBI jetzt, ja wir wollen oder drängen seit 2010 sogar schon auf Änderungen. Quellen TKÜ im Facebook-Chat, ja nur das wäre dann keine Quellen TKÜ, sondern eine, ne, sie würden ja auf Facebook abhören. Also nicht an der Quelle, sondern so eine...
Im Prinzip die Backdoor bei Skype.
Sie wollen eine Backdoor. Und jetzt sagen sie, das finde ich echt interessant, ihre Argumentation, sie sagen ja, wir sehen Bußgelder vor für die Unternehmen, die bei unseren Anordnungsüberwachungen nicht mitmachen. Und diese Anordnung wäre etwas, die dann erfolgt für eine einzelne Person. Dann wird gesagt, lieber Google, hier, wir wollen jetzt einmal bitte alles. Und dann sagt der Google, ja, hier. Und dann ist das okay. Oder der Google sagt, ne, haben wir irgendwie keinen Bock drauf. Und dann sieht das FBI vor, sie wollen mindestens 25.000 Dollar tägliches Bußgelde dafür dann haben.
Dann muss ja wehtun.
Genau. Und ihre Argumentation ist aber, dass sie dadurch kleine Firmen nicht in so einen enormen Zwang bringen, in diese Infrastruktur auszubauen. Weil in dem Moment, wo du eine kleine Firma bist, du im Zweifelsfall sehr wenige Anfragen hast, was dir das Abhören deiner Nutzer angeht. Das heißt, du musst da jetzt noch nicht irgendwie so eine LA, Lawful Intercept Schnittstelle bauen. Du kannst aber im Zweifelsfall noch den einen Nutzer von deinen 1000 oder 10.000, den du überwachen sollst, dann auch von mir aus per Hand über MySQL Statements oder Firewall-Regeln überwachen. Das Interessante finde ich dabei, also du klingt ja erstmal sinnvoll.
Also für kleine Firmen ist die staatliche Überwachung durchzuführen billiger als für große Firmen.
Sie sind nicht unbedingt sofort dazu gezwungen, sich ein eigenes Rack dahin zu stellen, was nichts anderes macht als nur die Intercept-Anfragen der Regierung behandeln. Ein größeres Unternehmen wird das dann irgendwann machen, kommen müssen, weil sie so viele Anfragen bekommen, dass sie den Prozess automatisieren müssen. Während man den anderen Firmen sagen könnte, die eine Anfrage, die wir im Jahr kriegen, die machen wir von Hand. Spannenderweise hat das dann zur Folge, dass du nicht mehr geneigt bist, sichere Kommunikationssysteme zu bauen als kleine Firmen. Genau, das Gegenteil, weil das ist ja billiger. Genau, wenn du jetzt sagst, du baust ein vernünftiges Kommunikationssystem mit einer vernünftigen Verschlüsselung, wo du gar nichts von hast, die ökonomischen Anreize dafür sind ohnehin klein. Aber das heißt, dass du dann die Angst vor dir sehen musst, dass irgendwann die USA sagen, hier 25.000 Dollar Strafe pro Tag, weil du ein System gebaut hast, dass du gar nicht unseren Vorstellungen abhören kannst.
So, was machen wir jetzt damit? Ich meine, wenn Facebook abgehört werden kann und dazu gezwungen werden soll, dann betrifft das ja irgendwie auch alle anderen Plattformen. Alle anderen Plattformen, uns, nicht nur Amerikaner, sondern ganz viele Menschen. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie progressiv ist, könnte man jetzt sagen, liebes Facebook, kommt doch nach Deutschland. Wir haben das nicht.
Wir haben nur Beschranztaten aufgeholt. Das ist ihr Traumziel, ist da stark zu bezweifeln. Da treten sich gleich den Schar ein.
Der im Übrigen auch Informationsfreiheitsbeauftragter ist, wie ich immer wieder gerne feststelle. Das vergessen die meisten Leute, dass die Datenschutzbeauftragten im Bund und Länder nicht nur Datenschutzbeauftragte sind, sondern auch Informationsfreiheitsbeauftragte. Das Schöne, wenn man jetzt spinnt, wäre ja, bei solchen Maßnahmen kommen ja immer wieder vor. Also gerade in großen westlichen Industriestraten ist es ja auch opportun, von Gesetzgeberseite aus zu sagen, wir verpflichten Firmen, irgendwelche Maßnahmen für uns durchzuführen. Und das ist entweder mit Zwang oder mit Anreizen. Ich glaube, Anreize haben wir da Beispiele dafür, dass es Anreize gibt für Firmen.
Anreize, was zum Beispiel?
Na, wir bezahlen euch das oder ihr habt halt irgendwie...
Ich glaube, dass jetzt unbedingt so ein Anreiz ist, ich glaube, das ist eher so eine Forderung der Firmen oder Verbände, um solche Maßnahmen noch weiter nach hinten zu drängen, weil es für den Staat auf dem Papier dann erst mal zu teuer wird. Weil letztlich haben sie ja damit auch Kosten. Aber eigentlich, wenn sie wirklich an ihren Kunden ein Interesse haben, müssten sie eigentlich an sowas kein Interesse haben. Ich meine, jetzt ist es natürlich schon so, dass man einen Einzelfall nach Forschung sehr wohl sich gut begründen lässt in vielen Fällen. Da muss man jetzt nicht lange nachdenken. Das ist ja nicht der Punkt, sondern es geht eben um das systematische Abschnorcheln. Und dass die Behörden direkt an der Pipe sind, ohne für den Einzelfall eine Begründung zu brauchen. Prinzip reden wir hier eigentlich auch von Vorratsdatenspeichern.
Das wird sogar noch viel spannender. Die Behörde selber kann ja über Datenschutz argumentieren, dass sie dem Provider nicht die Information geben kann, welche Person gerade verdächtigt wird. Und dadurch kann die Behörde argumentieren.
Ich brauche eine Schnittstelle, wo ich selber Hand anlegen kann.
Aus Datenschutzgründen brauchen wir einfach einmal den Monitoring-Port von eurem Switch. Und falls dann noch irgendwie IPSEC draufgesprochen wird, den Key dazu. Wir wollen, damit ihr nicht wisst, wen wir gerade überwachen. Kannst du so argumentieren?
Ich denke mir, ich höre ja auch immer eure Sendung. Übrigens auch Danke von mir dafür. Ich lerne immer sehr viel. Unabhängig von der aktuellen Empörungslage auf Twitter. Da gibt es ja manchmal, wenn so Dinge in den Grade gerückt. Das finde ich immer sehr schön. Aber ich sehe das ja immer wieder und ich frage mich halt, wie kann man diesen Trend rumdrehen?
Ich sage dir meine Antwort dazu.
Okay, jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Das Problem ist, ich glaube, einen Ansatz, den du benennst, ist sicherlich wichtig, dass man da untereinander die Rahmenkrämpfe einstellt. Wobei die auch nicht so groß und so übel sind, wie man sich das vielleicht vorstellt. Aber sie sind einfach aufgrund der Gegebenheiten vorhanden. Der nächste Punkt ist oder die nächste Gefahr, die sich stellt, ist, dass wir eine Gegnerschaft haben, die immer wieder einfach Sachen versuchen kann. Wir haben das ja sogar jetzt irgendwie. Schau dir diese CISPA-Sachen an. Die hauen den ganzen Scheiß einfach ein halbes Jahr später nochmal auf den Tisch. Inzwischen eine Telekom, die hingeht und heute sich den Shitstorm abholt für Scheiße in drei Jahren.
Und 2016 das einfach macht.
Das heißt, eine Telekom macht eigentlich sehr schlau Salamitaktik. Die fangen erstmal an. Hier übrigens geleakte Papiere. Dann gibt es schon den ersten. Und irgendwann hast du dein Ziel erreicht und nie einen nennenswerten Gegenwind erfahren, der dich an der Zielerreichung gehindert hätte. Und genau das haben wir ja siehe Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch. Dann nimmst du das Ganze als Bestandsdatenauskunft und schiebst das euch von hinten quer rein, statt von vorne oben. Und das wird immer wieder passieren. Das heißt, was du eigentlich brauchst, ist einerseits dieses breite Bündnis, andererseits aber auch mal wirklich Endlösungen. Ich hab das genauso genannt in dem Diggiges Vortrag am 29C3.
Tim macht den Parteigruß.
Jetzt können wir unseren Podcast zumachen.
Du musst einfach...
Als vergleichspolitischer Sprecher meiner Fraktion heißt das jetzt.
Die netzpolitische Endlösung. Die muss einfach herbeigeführt werden. Ich hab immerhin nicht gesagt, dass wir die Netzfrage klären.
Linus, die Netzfrage, genau. Wir haben doch noch gar nicht geklärt, was diese Lösung ist.
Ja, und ich glaube, diese Lösung ist ein Verbot.
Die Lösung ist kein Verbot.
Die Lösung muss festgelegt werden, ein Verstoß gegen die Netzneutralität muss verboten werden. Das kannst du nicht über Anreize machen.
Bist du jetzt bei der Überwachung oder bist du jetzt bei der Netzneutralität?
Ich bin jetzt bei der Endlösung. In unserem Antrag ist jetzt DPI auch mit drin. Also das DPI ist auch eine Verletzung von Netzneutralität. Rein technisch. Ob man jetzt dann irgendwelche Monitoring-Schnittstellen dann auch mit rein nimmt, also die Geräte und Knotenpunkte einer freien Infrastruktur, die von irgendwem betrieben wird, die halt nur zu dem Zweck des Betriebs betrieben werden darf und nicht irgendwie von einer Seite überwacht werden soll. Oder der freie Wirtschaftsbetrieb, ich meine, das ist ja auch Eingriff in das freie Wirtschaften von so einer Firma wie Facebook. Das könnte man ja auch verbieten. Da kann man sagen, der Staat darf da nicht reinhorchen, weil das würde deren Bilanzen ändern. Also deren Geschäftsmodell würde sich ändern. Ich sehe das auch so. Gleichzeitig müssen wir uns darüber einig werden, was wir wollen. Meine Utopie wäre ja jetzt gewesen, es gibt einen Deutschland, in dem so etwas wie TPI nicht vorkommt, in dem BDA nicht ist und die Providers nicht gezwungen werden, irgendwie ewig lang Speicher anzuhäufen, damit es dann eine Abfrage geben kann. Und wir locken die Firmen hierher, wir sagen, wir haben zwar krassen Datenschutz, damit müsst ihr umgehen, aber wir reden euch wenigstens nicht in eure Infrastruktur rein und ihr könnt euch sicher sein, dass das hier nicht passiert. Und ihr könnt hier irgendwie wirtschaften im Gegensatz zu Amerika. Ihr könnt, wenn ihr hier sitzt, euren Kunden sagen, das bleibt bei uns. Ich sehe aber nicht, dass wir in Deutschland eine Mehrheit dafür finden, Facebook hier ein Heim zu bieten. Dafür ist die Angst vor Facebook, die geschürt wird, viel zu groß. Dafür haben wir gesehen, was mit Google Street View passiert ist. Es ist halt die Frage, was ist die Lösung? Wo wollen wir eigentlich hin? Wollen wir ein Land in den Firmen wie Facebook und Google wirtschaften können und auch die Leute damit klarkommen, weil wir ihnen eine Hilfestellung möglicherweise dabei geben, mit Google umzugehen und mit Facebook umzugehen? Können wir uns darauf einigen, wenigstens? Dann kannst du auch mit Anreizen arbeiten. Dann musst du natürlich auch mit gesetzlichen Regelungen arbeiten, aber dann kannst du auch mit Anreizen arbeiten. Aber ich sehe noch nicht, dass das Ziel klar ist.
Ich meine, für mein Netz soll das eigentlich keine Rolle spielen, wo die Firma ist, die da irgendwie arbeitet. Da bin ich jetzt auf dünnem Eis, weil der Standortfaktor für die Firmen häufig eben genau das ist, wo der Datenschutz am liebsten ist.
Das ist auch ein Argument für uns immer gewesen, bei Zensursula zum Beispiel. Also es ist ja die Standortfrage, wo liegt die Firma oder wo steht der Server? Was ist justiziabel, in welchem Bereich? War ja immer eins unserer Argumente.
Ja, und ich meine, wenn du jetzt hier in Deutschland Dienste anbiest, die von Russen genutzt werden, dann wird es ja auch nicht unbedingt jetzt mit russischem Gesetz konfrontiert werden. Also es ist wirklich schwer zu lösen. Ich denke, wir haben jetzt auch gar nicht hier den Anspruch, das Final lösen zu können. Aber wir haben zumindest mal den Konflikt ganz gut aufgezeigt, dass es ja eben einfach keine einfache Lösung gibt. Nichtsdestotrotz, was ich immer wieder vermisse in dieser Debatte, ist einfach auch mal die Würdigung dieses neuen Grundrechts, was zwar mal ausgerufen wurde, aber so recht noch keine Anwendung gefunden hat in meiner Wahrnehmung. Nee, das Grundrecht, wie heißt es nochmal so schön? Auf die Integrität informationstechnischer Systeme, was ja ein Ergebnis war, der Klage gegen die, hilft mir, hier von der Bettina, war das die Online-Durchsuchung? Ja, ich glaube gegen die Online-Durchsuchung. Wo ja das Verfassungsgericht festgestellt hat, dass es eben ein solches Grundrecht eben gibt. Also nicht im Sinne von einem Gesetz, sondern eben sozusagen vom Verfassungsgericht einen sich aus der sonstigen Rechtslage und vor allem der verfassungsergebenden Grundrecht, dass man eben, wenn man jetzt eigene Infrastruktur hat, dass diese eben auch einen privaten Schutz genießt, selbst wenn sie sich nicht in meiner Wohnung befindet. Und man könnte im Prinzip auch von diesem Grundrecht aus argumentieren, dass selbst wenn ich jetzt bei Facebook mein digitales Heim finde und es sich dabei nicht um einen eigenen Computer handelt, aber sozusagen diese Informationsverarbeitung, die für mich durchgeführt wird und die ja auch nach wie vor dieselben privaten Daten vorhält, die ich vielleicht sonst über meinem eigenen Server gehabt hätte, dass auch das unter dieses Grundrecht fallen könnte.
Das hatten wir bei der Quellen-TKÜ auch im Abgeordnetenhaus als Argument und beziehungsweise als Streitpunkt, dass man in der aktuellen technischen Welt, in der wir leben und der Kommunikationsverhalten, wenn man das in den Betracht sieht, den Schreibtisch des Zuhause nicht von dem Server trennen kann, auf dem man sich gerade befindet, und auch nicht von irgendwo anders trennen kann. Also allein schon irgendwie die Skype-Verbindung von A nach B ist ja dann eine gemeinsame Plattform, die sich irgendwo befinden kann. Und ich glaube da, ich hab das nicht mehr genau vorm Auge, ist das juristische Argument gewesen, dass genau diesen Aspekt der Trennung zwischen Heimcomputer, Personalcomputer sozusagen und dem Server, auf dem ich mich gerade befinde, wenn ich mit Facebook interagiere, dass das nicht im Urteil aufgearbeitet wurde. Also gerade in diesem Urteil steht das nicht drin. Das Problem wurde nicht behandelt und nicht ausreichend. Wenn man jetzt juristisch argumentieren möchte und wirklich eine Verhinderung von solchen Bestrebungen wie der Quellen-TKÜ ein juristisches Argument bringen möchte, müsste man ein weiteres Urteil anstrengen. Darum kümmern, was ist denn auf dem Server, auf dem ich gerade bin? Was ist denn im Gegensatz zu dem Laptop, den ich auf den Shows habe, was ist denn auf dem Server? Das könnte man auch machen. Das wäre tatsächlich eine konstruktive Herangehensweise.
Oder auch einfach mal ein Gesetz entsprechend auf Basis dieser Gutrechtsfeststellung erlassen, die einfach mal genau beschreibt, was denn nun auf Basis dieser generellen Erkenntnis daraus ganz konkret folgen sollte. Naja, ich denke wir haben jetzt erstmal genug gefordert. Probleme mit dem Internet gibt es nicht nur in den USA und in Deutschland, sondern vor allem auch gerade in Syrien. Ein Land, was an Problemen gerade nicht arm ist. Und jetzt mit einem Bürgerkrieg, ich glaube schon zum zweiten oder dritten Mal, gab es einen nachhaltigen Internet-Ausfall, der jetzt nicht unbedingt nach Unfall aussieht. Und es ist nicht so, dass die Bits sich langsam durchquitschen, sondern es ist mal wieder so ein Ausschalten.
Der Telefon ist direkt mit kaputt gegangen.
Telefon auch? Naja gut, das ist halt... Kommt sozusagen jetzt alles irgendwie über ein Netz. Also wurde im Prinzip die Telekommunikation abgeschaltet, kann man mal de facto feststellen. Was das nun für konkrete Gründe hat, wissen wir nicht. Nur, dass die Internetinfrastruktur schon noch im Wesentlichen in der Hand des regierenden Regimes liegt. Und das wurde schon bekannt, dass zumindest auch im lokalen Rahmen solche Maßnahmen dann auch immer kamen, kurz bevor es wieder irgendwo richtig knallen soll, um dann eben die Kommunikationskanäle flachzulegen.
Aktivisten nehmen da noch irgendwie Satellite-Uplinks oder so?
Es gibt wohl auch noch Dial-ups. Ich hab jetzt auf Twitter heute gesehen, dass auch Nummern für Dial-ups rumgeschickt wurden.
Ich dachte genau, deshalb geht das Telefon nicht.
Ja, es kann ja sein, dass nicht alle... Du hast ja auch immer noch Botschaftsleitungen, die da irgendwie rumliegen. Es waren auf jeden Fall noch Dial-up-Nummern irgendwie im Umlauf. Das müsste man jetzt nochmal genau nachprüfen. Satelliten ab links, es gibt ja auch diese Initiative, die 2011 mal von einigen Piraten und Telekom-Aktivisten gestartet wurde, 12 miles ahead. Nur ist Syrien nicht durch so viel Küste gesegnet, dass man damit ein Boot davor fahren kann, so wie es ja mal in Ägypten geplant war. Aber ich glaube, da muss es auch neue Angriffspunkte auf so eine Situation geben. Vielleicht kriegt man ja eine Kooperation mit Israel hin und stellt sich auf die Gulanhöhen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, aus Israel kannst du da rüber werfen.
Eben, eben. Man hofft, dass da...
Die Israelis haben auch kein Interesse daran.
Ich glaube schon, dass die Israelis ein Interesse daran haben, dass in Syrien eine Kommunikationsinfrastruktur wieder funktioniert. Weil die wollen wissen, was mit den ABC oder BC-Waffen, die man in Syrien vermutet, passiert. Weil davor haben die ja Angst, dass die einfach über die Grenze geschmuggelt werden können, wenn niemand drauf aufpasst. Und auch da müsste man, glaube ich, ran. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob es so etwas wie Telekomics noch mal gibt. Eine Organisation, die sich darum kümmern kann. Ich hoffe, sowas gibt es. Und wenn ich da irgendwie unterstützen kann, dann mache ich das auch gerne. Das ist, glaube ich, einfach notwendig, weil freie Kommunikation, überhaupt Kommunikation, auch mit der Außenwelt, ist ein Grundbaustein dafür, dass das besser werden kann.
Es gab da von Metronaut das wunderbare Bildchen, als der Internet-Blackout in Ägypten stattfand, wo dann so eine Wüste zu sehen ist, eine Pyramide, und es wird gesagt, einfach mal abschalten. Das belegt auch meine These von unserer eigenen Abstumpfung. Als in arabischem Frühling das Internet ausfiel, da war das noch der völlige Irrsinn, unglaublich undenkbar. In Syrien passiert es jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal. In Deutschland passiert es jetzt auch bald, und da sogar einzelnen Bürgern. Das heißt, man stumpft da irgendwie gegen ab. Die kriegen das hin, uns zu zermürben und kaputt zu langweilen. Das ist wirklich schwierig. Das ist aber auch die beste Taktik, die du hast, die Salamitaktik.
Das meinte ich auch mit meinem Zitat von Tante Stwiet. Ich merke, ob das jetzt unsere lokalen Probleme sind. Drosselkomm-Aufreger oder Infrastruktur, oder eben die Sachen, die in Syrien passieren, Internet-Switches und Überwachungen in Amerika. Das haben wir alle irgendwann mal so oft gehört, dass es an uns vorbeizieht. Das ist glaube ich die allergrößte Gefahr. Es gab jetzt auch eine Internet-Enquete-Kommission im Deutschen Bundestag, die hat teilweise total tolle Dinge beschlossen. Ich glaube nicht, dass...
Eine WOK-Kommission, lass uns die bloß.
Ich meine, da ist das selbe. Das ist super, dass man darüber diskutiert hat in einem parlamentarischen Rahmen. Und dass da was irgendwie rausgekommen ist. Oder vielleicht ist es auch nicht gut, was dabei rausgekommen ist. Aber es wird jetzt einfach kein Thema mehr sein. Wenn wir es nicht zum Thema machen, wird es kein Thema sein. Und die Frage ist, wie machen wir es zum Thema? Nochmal der Appell. Nicht nächstes Jahr den nächsten Sascha Lobos Überraschungsvortrag mit demselben Thema wie die beiden Jahre davor zu hören, sondern irgendwie was Neues.
Der Sascha Lobos Vorteil war ohnehin dieses Jahr ein Tiefpunkt auf seiner eigenen Vortragskraft. Oder Vortragskunst. Insofern glaube ich, sind wir alle angehalten, ihm nächstes Jahr was Besseres bieten zu können. Lass uns jetzt nicht mehr mit dem Sascha Lobos Vortrag an.
Das fahre ich wirklich depressiv.
Von Syrien zu Sascha Lobo halte ich jetzt auch schon wirklich in echtem Kunstgriff hier im Themenschwenk. Ich versuche das mal zu retten an dieser Stelle, indem wir einfach zum nächsten Thema voranschreiten. Da geht es jetzt auch mal ganz konkret um das, was ihr in der Piratenfraktion so treibt. Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, bist du auch selbst extrem involviert in dieses Projekt. Wir haben es hier in Logbuch Netzpolitik 51 Anfang des Jahres schon einmal angesprochen. Allerdings noch mit wenig Detailkenntnis. Die kannst du ja vielleicht jetzt noch mal kurz nachreichen. Das geht natürlich um BERwatch, eine Plattform, die von der Berliner Piratenfraktion betrieben wird, kann man das so sagen. Das ist richtig. Die eben dazu da ist, dieses ganze Dokumentengeschehen und das ganze Dokumentierungsgeschehen rund um den BER-Skandal, Skandal kann man das glaube ich nennen. Desaster aufzuarbeiten und dabei eben ein elektronisches System zu nutzen, zu Recherche, was es so bisher noch nicht gab. Soweit meine Zusammenfassung, vielleicht kannst du ja nochmal deinen eigenen Pitch hinterher schmeißen. Was ist BERwatch? Was macht es anders als andere Systeme?
Es gibt keine anderen Systeme, die vergleichbar sind.
Na gut, man hätte ja auch ein Wiki nehmen können. Also ich meine sozusagen als Informationssystem.
Als Informationssystem, als Dokumentationsbasis kann man natürlich auch ein Wiki nehmen, das ist richtig. Aber was BERwatch macht, und das war auch die initiale Idee, ist, diese ganzen unendlichen Aktenberge, die wir bekommen, digital händelbar zu machen für die Öffentlichkeit. Und zwar so, dass ich sie mir sowohl im Volltext durchsuchen kann, und darüber auch Abfragen machen kann, als auch im Internet angucken. Es gibt mehrere OCR-Mechanismen, die dahinter stehen, sodass auch, also nicht alles, aber auch relativ saubere Handschrift auf einem Dokument wird auch miterkannt, da haben wir drauf geachtet. Und das zentrale Eigenschaft dieses BERwatch ist halt der Dokumenten-Viewer, der mir eine runtergerendete Ansicht als JPEG im Browser bietet, sodass ich da auch so lesen kann, dass ich dieses Seiten-Feeling habe, ich bin auf der und der Seite, auch seitenweise kommentieren kann, gleichzeitig aber in der Datenbank hinten den kompletten Text des Dokuments habe. Das bietet das halt zusammen, sehe ich nicht, gibt es nicht. Also habe ich bisher noch keine Software gefunden, die das macht, das ist auch ein relativ spezieller Fall. Dazu hat sich dann, wir haben das ja diskutiert, ich habe das mal in einem Interview gesagt, da hat sich dann der gute Holger, Holger Drees gemeldet, der auch in dem Bereich Open Data unterwegs ist, und hat gesagt, ja, ich habe da was, worum man das erweitern könnte, wo man diese Funktionalität, die ihr haben wollt, oder die ihr schon habt, die hatten wir vorher schon so als Skript programmiert, einbetten kann. Und zwar ist das dieses Big Projects, Watch, so nennt er das, wo er eine relativ ausgefeilte Semantik hat und sagt, es gibt irgendwie Personen, es gibt Ereignisse, es gibt einen Verlauf, es gibt natürlich Dokumente und Weblinks. Wenn man sich so ein großes Projekt anguckt, sollte man das alles auf einer Plattform darstellen können. Und wir haben den dann bezahlt und gebeten, das für uns anzupassen. Inzwischen sind wir bei Version 2.5 und es hat sich dann doch einiges getan, seit dem letzten Mal, dass ihr das hattet. Inzwischen gibt es nur noch eine Kommentarfunktion, die so semi-intelligent ist. Also jemand, der dort einen Inhalt, einen Dokument kommentieren möchte, eine Seite, einen Inweis dazu hat, was er dort gelesen hat und uns einen Hinweis geben möchte, wo wir weiter recherchieren in diesem Aktenberg als Untersuchungsausschuss oder auch den Leuten draußen, Journalisten, die auf der Plattform sind. Der macht einen Kommentar. Der ist in der Lage, dann eben zu dem Kommentar Dokumente zu verknüpfen. Verschiedene Dokumente, die er gefunden hat. Auch Personen, das kommt dann durch so ein Dropdown-Menü, also so eine Autovervollständigung, relativ komfortabel inzwischen. Was dann den Informationsberg verdichtet und quer verlinkt. Das ist der Crowdsourcing-Ansatz, den wir haben wollen.
Wer nutzt denn die Plattform tatsächlich?
Bürgerinitiativen ganz viel. Wobei wir da das Problem haben, dass diese Bürgerinitiativen oftmals aus Menschen bestehen, die eher mit Zettel und Stift unterwegs sind. Die lesen zwar auch gerne im Internet, die betreiben auch irgendwie Blogs. Aber dieses Kommentieren und Verknüpfung und dann mit der Plattform arbeiten, das ist bei vielen noch nicht so drin.
Also da könnte mehr zurückfließen.
So oft, wenn man im Internet nach Meinungen fragt, die differenziert und konstruktiv sein sollen. Es kommen aber Kommentare, es kommen auch Verknüpfungen. Das ist sehr schön. Wir geben jetzt auch, das ist eine neue Funktion, Rechercheaufträge. Wir sagen, woran wir gerade sind, beziehungsweise wofür wir keine Zeit haben. An das Internet. Es gibt hier einen eigenen Reiter, der heißt Rechercheaufträge zu bestimmten Fragen, die der Untersuchungsausschuss bearbeiten soll. Wenn man hier auf Fragen geht, dann findet man dort alle Fragen, die im Untersuchungsauftrag stehen. Die haben auch eigene Seiten und eigene Links. Da kann man nachlesen, ob wir die Frage schon beantwortet haben oder nicht. Zu diesen Fragen gibt es auch Rechercheaufträge. Gibt es andere Gutachten zur Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung als die, die wir bisher dort verlinkt haben? Ist euch irgendetwas bekannt? Habt ihr mal einen Brief nach Hause bekommen, wo das erwähnt wurde oder solche Sachen? Um eben auch noch mal ganz gezielt die Leute anzusprechen und nicht damit alleine zu lassen, dass sie jetzt überall kommentieren können.
Da wird auch gesagt, in welchen Dokumenten man suchen soll? Heißt das hier, in welchen schon was gefunden wurde? Was ich hier so Grundwassersituationen...
Genau, der Rechercheauftrag an der Stelle heißt, hat sich jemand mit entsprechender fachlicher Expertise mit einem vorhandenen BER-Gutachten auseinandergesetzt. Das bezieht sich dann auf eine Frage, und zwar genau auf die Frage Planfeststellungsverfahren, wo man Weblinks findet, Personen dazu findet und Dokumente dazu findet.
Und wie viele Leute greifen sowas auf? Also ist das jetzt noch eine Hoffnung? Oder wie sind tatsächlich Leute, die damit ihre Freizeit verbringen?
Es gibt eine ganze Menge, erstaunlich viele Menschen, die damit ihre Freizeit verbringen. Oftmals schicken die uns aber lieber E-Mails und Briefe. Das ist noch so das Problem. Was aber auf jeden Fall wirkt, und wo die Leute uns auch sehr dankbar dafür sind, ist, dass wir halt eine relativ einfache Möglichkeit haben, unsere Arbeit zu dokumentieren. So ein Untersuchungsausschuss krankt ja auch oftmals daran, dass das Ergebnis ja erst dann feststeht, wenn der Abschlussbericht fertig ist, der in einem furchtbaren Juristendeutsch geschrieben werden muss, weil das ja so eine Art Verhandlung ist, ein Urteil gefällt werden soll. Und wir versuchen das halt kontinuierlich zu machen und weiterzuführen. Das hilft sehr. Dazu haben wir jetzt auch so ein paar Features, die man haben will, nämlich RSS-Feeds eingefügt, sodass man sehen kann, wann ein neues Dokument hochgeladen wird, wann ein Kommentar kommt, wann zu einer Frage eine Antwort kommt, wann es da weitergeht. Und wir bieten inzwischen auch eine API an. Das heißt, man kann jetzt, was weiß ich, Michael Greil, kann losgehen und sagen, wir wollen jetzt eine Visualisierung machen. Ich greppe mal wie oft in den Dokumenten Erfolgsgeschichte oder Angela Merkel zu finden. Das geht auch auf allen Ebenen in dem System. Kann man sich angucken. Würde mich sehr freuen, wenn da mal jemand ein generisches Visualisierungstool drüber laufen lässt, weil das ist im Prinzip Text. Und glaubt mir, Text können wir umgehen im Internet anzwischen. Und dann würden wir das auch so veröffentlichen. Weil jede Darstellung hilft. Und auch die Frage Big Data und wie man jetzt auch mit so einem komplexen Themenfeld wie dem BER-Disaster umgeht, die ist ja im politischen Kontext immer daran aufgehängt, dass gerade konservative Kräfte behaupten, das nützt ja nichts, weil das überfordert ja die Menschen. Und mit so einer Plattform versuchen wir eben auch zu beweisen, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Das ist schon was hilft.
Und denkst du, dass euch der Beweis auch gelingen wird? Also zeichnet sich das schon irgendwie ab, dass ihr da nicht nur Arbeit habt?
Wir kriegen aufgrund der Plattform und der Darstellung, die wir dort haben, eben ganz konkrete Journalistenanfragen von investigativen Journalisten zum Beispiel, die dann eben wesentlich besser informiert sind, als sie sein könnten, wenn sie die Dokumente nicht lesen können oder erst zu uns kommen müssten, um die Dokumente durchzublättern. Wir kriegen Zusendungen. Wir haben ja auch so eine Privacy Box für anonyme Zusendungen drin, die sich auf Fragen in der Plattform beziehen und auf Dokumente beziehen. Wie gesagt, die betroffenen Initiativen und Bürgerinitiativen, die muss man auch immer wieder sagen, ja, in allen Punkten, für die sie gekämpft haben, Recht behalten haben inzwischen. Also Flugrouten, Schallschutz, Mehrkosten, Standortfrage ist genau die Probleme, die sie seit 10 Jahren, 15 Jahren anprangern, sind jetzt die Probleme und niemand kann mehr leugnen, dass das die Probleme sind. Da funktioniert die Zusammenarbeit aufgrund der Plattform extrem viel besser als gedacht. Naja, und es ist auch eine Frage, wie man in Zukunft solche Prozesse im Parlament an sich öffnen möchte. Und da hilft uns die Plattform dabei, jetzt Grundsatzentscheidungen und Diskussionen herbeizuführen. Es gibt gerade einen Rechtsstreit des Abgeordnetenhauses, der Meinung ist, ich soll die Plattform wieder abschalten. Über diese Meinung bin ich offensichtlich nicht. Das wird jetzt erstmal in so einem Gutachtenstreit ausarten und dann wird das sicherlich auch vor Gericht ausgefordert werden müssen. Aber es geht halt im Prinzip darum, Parlamente zu öffnen und parlamentarische Arbeit zu öffnen. Das lasse ich mir dann auch nicht nehmen, da mit dem Kopf durch die Wand zu rollen.
Sie haben sich erst jetzt darüber beschwert. Das ist die Beschwerdefalle oder der...
Klaus Wohlreit zum Beispiel hat sich im Juni schon darüber beschwert, dass wir in ein blödes WebDAF-Repository irgendwie Dokumente von ihm hochgeladen haben, wo er der Meinung war, die wären vertraulich gewesen. Jetzt geht es darum, dass der wissenschaftliche parlamentarischen Dienst des Abgeordnetenhauses die Rechtssicherheit der Beweisführung im Untersuchungsausschuss gefährdet sieht durch diese Plattform. Das heißt, die Informationen sind, also verknabbt gesagt behauptet dieses Gutachten, dass die Informationen dadurch, dass sie öffentlich diskutiert werden können, nicht mehr für die Beweisführung im Untersuchungsausschuss taugen.
Weil sie in dieser Plattform öffentlich dokumentiert werden können oder weil sie überhaupt öffentlich dokumentiert werden können?
Weil sie überhaupt öffentlich sind, drei Punkte. Erstens, das ist eine Beeinflussung von Zeugen. Ja, würde dann aber auch für jeden Zeitungsartikel potenziell gelten. Schwierig. Kann man im Zweifel dann immer im Untersuchungsausschuss im Einzelfall diskutieren, wenn man irgendwie den Verdacht hat, da ist eine Zeugenbeeinflussung vorgenommen, die Aussage ist nix wert, muss man halt darüber entscheiden. Zweiter Grund, ein former Juristischer, die Geschäftsordnung des Abgeordnetenhauses ist, was die Handhabung von öffentlichen Dokumenten angeht, nicht im 21. Jahrhundert angekommen, wen wundert's. Die sagt nämlich, die ist nur für die parlamentarische Arbeit da und dazu gehören, also öffentliche Dokumente sind nur zu verwenden für die parlamentarische Arbeit und dazu gehören Internetplattformen nicht. Haben wir noch nie gemacht, werden wir auch nicht anfangen. Und das dritte ist, und das ist ein wirkliches Problem, weil es dann auch mit höchstrichterlichen Entscheidungen einhergeht und koordiniert, die Firmen als herausgebende Stellen, auch Institutionen, also Verwaltungseinrichtungen, haben ein Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung. Und sie können und sie müssen sogar, wenn sie uns Dokumente liefern, die müssen sie uns hier liefern, so können sie sich ja nicht wehren, eine sogenannte Einstufung nach Geheimschutzordnungen vornehmen. Das heißt, diese Unterlagen sind aus dem und dem Grund entweder öffentlich, vertraulich oder Verschlusssache, Verschlusssache vertraulich, Verschlusssache geheim usw. Wir veröffentlichen sowieso nur die öffentlichen Dokumente, also die, die nicht eingestuft sind, weil andere, da würden wir uns strafbar machen, bis zu 5 Jahre Mindeststrafe und so. Das wollen wir sowieso nicht. Jetzt sagt aber das Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung, dass es einen Unterschied gibt, oder das so interpretiert, dass es einen Unterschied gibt zwischen der eben öffentlich, im Sinne von parlamentarischer Arbeit öffentlich und der Nutzung für eine Internetplattform dieser Dokumente. Also mit der Maßgabe, diese Dokumente sind öffentlich, heißt es noch nicht, dass ich der Nutzung für eine Internetplattform zugestimmt habe als Institution, die mir Dokumente gibt.
Mit so einer Scheiße musst du dich auseinander setzen.
Ja, das ist Arbeit eines Untersuchungsfrages, wenn man das nicht so machen will wie alle anderen davor. Das Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung für Unternehmen steht im Grundgesetz. Das heißt, da sind wir schon in ganz knackigen Begriffen. Das Problem, was das Abgeordnetenhaus damit eigentlich hat, ist, und deswegen wollen sie auch die Plattform gerne abschalten, dass es zwei Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteile gibt, die sagen, wenn, auch nicht nur Untersuchungsausschüsse, aber gerade Untersuchungsausschüsse, wenn Zweifel daran bestehen, dass so ein Abgeordnetenhaus, eine öffentliche Stelle, mit Dokumenten, die denen geliefert werden müssen, nicht ordnungsgemäß umgeht, das heißt, die Vertraulichkeit nicht sicherstellt, eben das Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung in dem Fall nicht beachtet, dann können sich die herausgebenden Stellen, die aufgeforderten Stellen weigern, Dokumente zu liefern. Das kann auch dazu führen, dass die Senatskanzlei als Vertreter der Exekutive in Zukunft immer sagt, also weil die Piraten, das ist jetzt die Argumentation der Gegenseite, weil die Piraten im Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus sitzen und die was mit Internet machen und Dinge ja ins Internet reinstellen, das kann das Abgeordnetenhaus nicht mehr sicherstellen, dass die Unterlagen, die wir als vertraulich kennzeichnen und als Abgeordnetenhaus geben, auch als vertraulich behandelt werden. Deswegen geben wir keine vertraulichen Dokumente mehr an das Abgeordnetenhaus.
Selbst unser Abgeordnetenhaus verkackt ihr uns.
Also ja genau, Piraten sind schuld. Das ist keine Erfindung der Netzgemeinde. Das ist im Prinzip die einfache Lösung, die Piraten aus dem Abgeordnetenhaus rauszuschmeißen. Weil es tatsächlich mit diesem gefühlten Risiko, weil jetzt Piraten in diesem Abgeordnetenhaus sind...
So weit werden sie ja jetzt nicht gehen, oder?
Nein, nicht die Senatskanzlei. Aber die herausgehenden Stellen für den Untersuchungsausschuss können das glaubhaft machen und können das mit diesen beiden Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteilen begründen.
Okay, das heißt, sie machen das jetzt auch?
Das ist die Frage, ob sie das machen. Also das muss zum Beispiel eine der...
Also wenn sie das jetzt machen, ist klar, wer klagt dann gegen die Unternehmen auf Herausgabe der Dokumente?
Der Untersuchungsausschuss.
Das heißt, so oder so, mit dem Ding landest du vor Gericht. Das war aber von vornherein klar.
Tja, Mensch, das klingt ja alles nicht so schön.
Ich finde das super, weil sowas musst du da durchstreiten. Du musst halt die Leute davon überzeugen, dass das Internet nicht per se schlecht ist. Und das kannst du, wie wir alle wissen, am Ende nur mit einem Gericht tun und nicht mit der Hoffnung, eine parlamentarische Mehrheit zu finden.
Okay, ihr bleibt da jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal hart bei eurer Linie. So wie ihr es bisher gefahren habt, und du siehst auch durchaus den Nutzen. Ich habe jetzt hier nochmal ein bisschen drin rumgeklickt. Was ich jetzt schön finde, ist, dass man hier auch wirklich so auf den ersten Klick hier auf Verlauf mal überhaupt einen schönen zeitlichen Zusammenhang bekommt, was so die wesentlichen Meilensteine der geschichtlichen Entwicklung dieser ganzen Desastergeschichte ausmacht. Und damit dann auch immer gleich verbunden, welche beteiligten Organisationen und Personen jetzt hier und dann eben auch mit konkreten Bezug auf Dokumente, was wir gemacht haben in dem Zusammenhang, ist eigentlich eine sehr schöne Sache.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine schöne Sache. Wie gesagt, abonniert euch den RSS-Feed, wenn euch das interessiert. Ihr müsst auch nicht alles abonnieren, sondern vielleicht nur neue Dokumente oder Antworten zu Fragen oder so, wenn ihr wissen wollt, was im Untersuchungsausschuss los ist. Ihr könnt auch den Twitter-Account, den Abdotnet-Account gibt es noch nicht, das müssen wir mal noch machen, wir haben sich noch Geld von der Fraktion besorgen, weil das würde ich nicht selber bezahlen. Aber das müssen wir mal noch machen und dort werden dann auch regelmäßig Berichte, wenn jetzt was Neues ist, wenn jetzt mal mehrere mehr als nur ein Dokument hochgeladen wurde, sondern irgendwie neue Verknüpfungen, neue Themenkomplexe angefasst wurde, wird dann auch da veröffentlicht, sodass es nicht spamming ist.
Und wenn ich jetzt so begeistert hier von den Herausforderungen, von denen du stehst, dass mir denke, so ein Untersuchungsausschuss, du klingst auch schon als begeistert hier. Jaja, ich wollte schon immer mal einen Untersuchungsausschuss leiten. Nix Schöneres. Jeder sollte einen haben. Könnte ich mir jetzt irgendwas einfallen lassen, was ich mal so untersuchen möchte. Hier, irgendwie Linus geht fremd in einen Podcast und so, was hat es damit auf sich? Da gab es schon verschiedene Vorfälle, es ist immer mal wieder unter Decknamen unterwegs.
Kannst du auch gleich fordern, dass der Regierende zurücktritt, deswegen ist es...
Ja, was nimmt man dann da? Also ist BERwatch sozusagen so in dieser Form, wie es jetzt hier ist, einfach ein Abreißblatt, ein Software, was man so sich mal eben irgendwo installieren kann und dann macht man seinen eigenen Untersuchungsausschuss?
Es kommt darauf an, wie komplex die Fragestellung ist. Also wie komplex jetzt das Problem ist, dass Linus Linus sag ich immer, Linus fremd geht. In irgendwelchen anderen Podcasts. Also wenn es nur ein Podcast ist, macht jetzt die Plattform vielleicht nicht so viel Sinn. Wenn du den Verdacht hast, dass er in 25 anderen Podcasts sitzt und noch dann bei der Content-Mafia Termine hat, die auf die inhaltliche Gestaltung des Podcasts einwirken.
Machen wir es mal ein bisschen praktikaler, das Szenario. Wenn ich jetzt eine Zeitung wäre, könnte ich ja auch diese Dokumente nehmen und mir sozusagen meine lokale Instanz schaffen und das dann eben auch noch so mit meinen geheimen Quellen anreichern und das einfach so als Recherche zu benutzen, oder?
Wobei, der Meinung bin ich, ich hab mehr geheime Quellen als die Zeitung.
Das mag ja sein, aber...
Ja, genau, das kann man machen. Mir wär's natürlich lieber, wenn es jetzt gerade um den BER geht, wenn mehr Journalisten, hallo liebe Journalisten, falls ihr zuhört, diese Plattform benutzen würden und wollen würden. Das muss man denen auch noch beibringen, dass das nichts Schlimmes ist, da mitzuarbeiten, weil es nicht nur einem selbst, sondern auch noch den Kollegen hilft, das Problem besser zu sich steigen. Aber ansonsten kann man das natürlich machen. Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie hunderte Dokumente zur Staatsoper gelegt bekommt, dann holt man sich im GitHub, kann man ja auch den Holger anschreiben, wenn man Hilfe bei der Installation braucht, diese Open-Source-Software, in der Version für BERwatch oder aber in der generischen Version, d.h.
die Open-Source-Software im Original.
Django Big Projects Watch findet man in dem GitHub-Repository von Holger D77.
Also Python?
Das ist Python, ja. Das ist nicht PHP. Deswegen ist das auch schnell, trotz 100.000 Dokumente.
Ja, weil man die schönen Python-Libraries alle nutzt.
Eben. Das kann man dann machen. Das kann man auch machen, wenn man jetzt z.B. so was wie eine Republika dokumentieren möchte. Da gibt es jetzt vielleicht schönere Sachen dafür, aber so von der Größe, mit der Komplexität. Man könnte damit z.B. auch eine deutsche Podcast-Community dokumentieren. Du hast einen Verlauf, du hast Personen, du hast möglicherweise Dokumente.
Das heißt, der Tim kann nicht nur gucken, wo ich fremdgegangen bin, sondern wo alle seine Med-Postcaster fremdgehen. Dann macht es Sinn.
Das kann nämlich auch noch was ganz Tolles, was mit diesem, gerade wenn du viele Dokumente hast, macht Sinn. Die Funktion, die ich jetzt noch kurz erwähnen wollen würde, ist eine Idee, die hat Holger gehabt, die ist super. Man hat ja gar kein Problem, in OCR-Arten Dokumenten zu suchen. Das geht ja ganz schnell. Wenn du jetzt aber dazu gleich relationiert irgendwie die regierenden Bürgermeister und alles, was damit zusammenhängt, finden möchtest, oder die Flughafengesellschaft, du aber nicht direkt nach Flughafengesellschaft Berlin-Brandenburg suchst, sondern nach irgendetwas, was damit zusammenhängt, findest du die Personen nicht. Das heißt, was er gemacht hat, ist, so Schlagworte, so Tags für alles, was nicht OCR durchsuchbar ist, zu definieren. Die tragen wir dort redaktionell ein, die kann man uns auch vorschlagen, sodass bei Klaus Woverait auch noch Regierender Bürgermeister, Aufsichtshaltsvorsitzender und so weiter und so fort steht, sodass man, wenn man im Volltext sucht, auch noch über die Stichworte mit den gleichen Suchergebnissen die Personen zum Beispiel bekommt und Verlauf und Ereignisse dazu bekommt, die man sonst nicht bekommen würde, wenn sie nicht genau den Namen tragen, wonach man sucht. Das ist relativ intelligent und das macht das Ganze noch schöner erfahrbar.
Schöne Anregungen, ich finde das ein interessantes Werkzeug. Vor allem finde ich es ganz interessant, die Fragestellung. Das reift bei mir auch gerade selbst im Hirn ein wenig. Wofür man das denn vielleicht noch anwenden könnte?
Für Ausschüsse an sich zum Beispiel haben wir das uns überlegt.
Offensichtlich, dass das jetzt für die politische Arbeit taugt, aber auch so historische Aufarbeitung von irgendetwas. Das kann ja sogar die eigene Anforschung mit einschließen. Ich denke, da geht es schon recht weit. Nun gut, das müssen wir jetzt nicht weiter ausführen. Linus, haben wir noch irgendwas? Nee, ne?
Ich glaube nicht. Nee, Republika ist jetzt vorbei. Bald, also für mich jetzt.
Für mich jetzt auch.
Ich trinke jetzt Bierchen.
Jetzt schon. Na, ich habe ja noch eine Sendung.
Ja, 20 Minuten noch, dann ist es vier.
Dann?
Es ist immer irgendwo vier links.
Kein Bier vor vier.
Ja, ich hoffe, das war nicht allzu langweilig.
Nee, nee. Vielleicht noch so zum Abschluss, dein Blick so auf die Republika sozusagen.
Mein Blick auf die Republika, so wie sie sich jetzt dieses Jahr auch wieder dargestellt hat, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, brauche ich nicht. Ich will eine Plattform zum Diskurs, zum Austausch haben. Ich will, dass Leute sich auf Podien streiten und dass man das dann am Ende in einem Abschlussplenum zusammenbringt, so dass man einen Ausblick bekommt. Ich will, dass Leute hier Projekte vorstellen, die sie im nächsten Jahr dann berichten. Das passiert mir zu wenig. Es gibt coole Ansätze, es gibt irgendwie auch coole Vorträge. Aber ich meine, den Sascha Lobo haben wir schon erwähnt, es gibt halt zu viele Vorträge, die ich im letzten Jahr schon mal gehört habe. Und Themen, die mir schon mal ausgebreitet wurden. Ich muss nicht zum fünften Mal die Konflikte, die beim Urheberrecht existieren, hören. Das, was hier auch großes Thema ist, da ist mir auch nicht viel Neues gegeben worden. Ich habe jetzt nicht alles gesehen, aber so in Diskussionen. Ich wünschte mir, die Republika wäre tatsächlich mehr so eine Plattform, wo der Blogger, die Bloggerin, die Firma, die was mit dem Internet macht, die Politik tatsächlich in den Streit eintreten und sich nicht nur selbst darstellen und die Probleme, die man aus dem Rundherum schon kennt, noch mal aufarbeiten.
Du greifst damit auf, was Gunther Dück in seinem Vortrag angesprochen hat. Das ist natürlich ein sehr schönes Ziel, dass du dir Debatten und Diskussionen wünschst. Ist aber irgendwie nicht das, was die Leute hören wollen. Die Leute wollen möglichst zu dem applaudieren, was sie selber schon immer toll fanden. Aber ich sehe den Punkt, den du machst. Ich bin auch, glaube ich, den größeren Teil der Republik habe ich damit verbracht, Leute zu treffen. Statt mir Vorträge anzuschauen. Aber es gab durchaus auch einige Vorträge aus einigen Themenbereichen, die für mich unterbelichtet waren, die ich als inspirierende Vorträge empfunden habe. Ich glaube, um wirklich ernsthafte Debatten zu führen, ist diese Veranstaltung halt auch zu groß.
Das weiß ich nicht. Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich denke, sie ist zumindest so groß, dass würdest du jetzt hier wirklich sagen, wir clashing jetzt mal hier was aufeinander, wir setzen jetzt jemanden vom Bitkom hin und jemanden vom Füllbot oder so. Dann hast du sofort diese Jauchisierung.
Das will ich ja auch nicht. Was ich meine, ist, mach mehr Politik. Ich meine, mach nicht einfach eine Vortragsreihe, sondern versuch, hier Politik mit reinzubringen. Das heißt, zumindest den Anspruch, eine Zielstellung zu formulieren am Ende. Das kommt immer auf die Moderation an. Das ist ganz wichtig. Ob du jetzt so eine Reihe machst mit nacheinander stattfindenden, gegensätzlichen Meinungen, wo die Leute von einem Vortrag zum anderen sind und am Ende hast du ein Podium, wie auch immer. Das war auch die Republik meiner Meinung nach noch nie. Aber das wäre ganz schön. Bring die Politik damit rein. Politik meine ich die Auseinandersetzung und die Debatte. Und nicht nur den Vortrag. Dass das nicht zu einer Talkshow-Situation werden soll, Jauchisierung ist ein schöner Begriff, da sind wir uns einig. Aber ich glaube, man kann es auch anders machen. Es muss auch nicht nur das sein. Genauso gut auch neue Sachen, neue Entwicklungen, neue Firmen vorstellen lassen, die Sponsoren hier wegen mir auch sich vorstellen lassen, das kann man ja nebenbei auch machen. Aber zumindest ein Stückchen diesen Anspruch verwirklichen, dass man hier auch Politik macht, dass man hier auch Agenda-Setting macht. Dass ich weiß, was ich in der Republika 14, zu der ich natürlich auch wieder gehen werde, wegen der Leute, wegen des Klassentreffens erwarten kann. So ein Ausblick, das ist im nächsten Jahr, im nächsten Jahr möchte ich zur Republika kommen und dann hören, was das Ergebnis der Diskussion ist, die wir hier geführt haben. Und das ist etwas, was die Veranstaltung, glaube ich, bereichern kann und was ich mir auch von allgemeinen Veranstaltungen wünsche.
Was wünschst du dir Linus?
Wünsche dir alles Gute. Tschüss. Also ich glaube, ich würde mir das auch wünschen, was Martin sagte, ich würde die These vertreten, dass es schwierig wird, das in so einer Veranstaltung unterzubringen. Ich bin insgesamt mit dieser, also mein eigener Erkenntnisgewinn hielt sich hier in Grenzen. Das aber vielleicht auch nicht verwunderlich, weil ich mich ja irgendwie andauernd mit all diesen Themen die ganze Zeit auseinandersetze und da kann ich mich selber nicht als Maßstab nehmen für den allgemeinen Erkenntnisgewinn, den ein zahlender Besucher durch diese Veranstaltung haben kann, welche Inspiration er hier bekommen kann. Ich bin allgemein dann doch mit dem Programm doch zufrieden. Das war, denke ich, schon ganz ordentlich. Andererseits wundere ich mich natürlich auch über mich selber, dass dieser aufregende Teil halt fehlt. Aber ich glaube, das liegt eher an uns als Leute, die das jetzt auch eben seit Jahren machen und weniger an den allgemeinen Besuchern. Aber insgesamt, ja klar, das ist ein Klassentreffen. Und bei Klassentreffen werden halt immer wieder die alten Geschichten erzählt.
Was ist mit dir, Tim? Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so ganz so sicher, was so deine Forderung nach mehr öffentlicher Streitkultur auf der Bühne betrifft. Also so Panels gehören bei mir so ein bisschen zum Hassformat schlechthin, weil ich das einfach selten bis nie erlebe, dass da irgendwie wirklich was Substanziales bei rauskommt. Weil es einfach dann auch immer häufig dazu führt, dass einfach irgendwie viel zu viele Leute eingeladen werden. Also zwei Leute, meiner Meinung nach, können sich noch streiten. Mit drei Teilnehmern wird es schon grenzwertig, aber bei vier ist es spätestens aus, aber eingeladen werden dann trotzdem fünf. Und da kommt man halt zu gar nichts. In gewisser Hinsicht bin ich da schon eher ein Freund von Kurzvorträgen und so weiter, die man dann zusammengruppiert. Das hat jetzt im Wesentlichen eigentlich was mit dem Veranstaltungsmanagement zu tun. Ansonsten ist so hier so ein bisschen der Hang zu so vielen Bühnen und Gleichzeitigkeiten, ich meine so unterm Strich, was haben wir hier, sieben Stages, dann gibt es hier irgendwie noch diesen Workshop-Bereich, der läuft ja so ein bisschen noch nebenbei. Das sind aber auch im Prinzip ja alles nur kleine Bühnen. Da ist es dann sehr schwierig, so eine Geschichte zu erzählen. Also man versucht so viel abzudecken, dass man dann irgendwann auch wirklich gar nichts mehr erzählt und es nicht schafft, dass sich so die Teilnehmer auf so einen bestimmten Pfad verdichten. Auf der anderen Seite sollte man vielleicht auch nicht zu viel an diesen Veranstaltungen festmachen, was ich mir ganz gut, also was ich mir wünschen würde, aber was hier etwas schwierig ist, rein jetzt vom räumlichen her oder den ansonsten nötigen finanziellen Aufwand, wäre halt einfach wirklich so mehr so dynamische Arbeitsbereiche zu schaffen. Dass man also wirklich auch so diese Dynamik mit, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, auf wen ich treffe. Aber ja, jetzt finden wir uns hier in einer interessanten Gruppe, jetzt schließen wir uns mal hier in so einen Raum rein, den man sich dann irgendwie so dynamisch klicken kann. Das fände ich mal ein ganz interessantes Experiment, aber das ist ja nochmal so veranstaltert.
Das ausgeweitet hätte gestern auch dieser Re-Campaign-Session für die Drossel-Com echt geholfen, weil das musste dann ja irgendwann beendet werden, weil nicht genug Platz ist.
Genau, so onstage kann man das dann auch nicht so richtig machen. Das kleine Gespräch, die riesige Veranstaltung findet statt, aber dazwischen skaliert das irgendwie noch nicht so richtig. Ich glaube, da muss man auch generell mal auf neue Lösungen kommen. Das selbe Problem, das sehe ich ja auch zum Beispiel beim Chaos-Communication-Kongress, genau dasselbe Problem, das ist da auch schon verstanden worden als Problem, ist so, dass man bei so einem Überangebot, wir hatten ja hier die Sandra in der Sondersendung auch schon, die gesagt hat, naja, wir hatten halt irgendwie sechsmal so viele Bewerbungen für Vorträge, als wir hier überhaupt unterbringen konnten, und das bei dieser Zahl, ja, da ist dann eben so eine Jury auch total überfordert, also passend zu so Systemen wie Liquid Feedback und so weiter, wünsche ich mir eigentlich demnächst mal auch eine passende Software, die eben euch solche Auswahlprozesse machen kann.
Gibt es ja, die sogar mit Liquid Demokrat, also mit Delegationsmechanismen sehr viel einfacher als Liquid Feedback arbeitet, die hat der Andreas Baum mit dem, also das Liquid Democracy EV gewesen, damals noch für das erste Politcamp in Berlin gemacht und dort auch vorgestellt. Die kann man da noch mal raussuchen, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie sie heißt, aber die war eine sehr einfache Session Crowdsourcen Planungsvoting-Maschine, wo auch so ein Delegationsprinzip mit drin ist, damit man eben nicht alle Sessions kennen muss und die miteinander vergleichen muss, sondern eben in verschiedenen Bereichen, die man vorher sortieren kann, jemanden delegieren kann, den man dafür für die Auswahl für kompetent hält.
Ja, interessant.
Und das war eine ganz schöne Sache. Ich weiß wirklich nicht mehr, wie sie heißt, das können wir vielleicht noch mal raus.
Okay, wir krammen das noch mal raus und packen das noch in die Links. Die Links, die Show notes zu unserer tollen Sendung, die jetzt glaube ich zum Ende gekommen ist, oder?
Ja, und die Links entstehen gerade in einem riesigen Beamer an unserer Seite und ich bin ganz begeistert. Das sieht aus wie bei den anderen Podcasts.
Ja, endlich habe ich das auch mal.
Ich glaube dein volles Zitat zu den Panels ist übrigens, da sitzen acht Leute, jeder sagt einmal was und am Ende muss man pissen. Wurde mir gerade noch so zugetragen, oder? Und ich muss nämlich jetzt auch pissen.
Achso, ich streite das jetzt erstmal alles ab. Martin, vielen Dank. Danke schön. Für das Dabeisein. Vielen Dank hier den tollen Zuhörern, die tatsächlich zwei Stunden auf mehr oder weniger alle ausgehalten haben. Linus?
Was sag ich jetzt noch?
Weiß ich nicht, ich dachte du hattest jetzt irgendwie so einen Kessenspruch auf der Lippe oder so, der dann hier so Zuschauer, Begeisterungsstürmer...
Acht Minuten bis vier.
Gleich gibt's Bier. Na gut, du bist jetzt auch entlassen, Linus.
Oh Scheiße, echt war die Sendung so schlimm.
Aber ich fühle den Schmerz, also du willst jetzt einfach...
Nee, am Ende sind die Piraten schuld.
Wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.